Have you ever felt that when
you are in your own house
cooking for yourself, that
you feel too comfortable, so
comfortable that you might
end up with a sad sandwich?
Well, this happens to me, too.
But when my husband joins the
party it's certainly taco night.
And of course, when you have
more help in the kitchen,
the result is much better.
Sadly, obviously, this
is not always the case
because working as a team can
be challenging too. Just imagine
a group of friends
trying to cook together.
They are used to
different things.
use different tools,
and if they are not
all in the same page,
it will be a disaster.
Well, this often happens when
you put data engineer or data
professionals and infrastructure
engineers to work together.
But if they speak
the same language,
they are said to build
successful products.
In this talk, I'm
going to tell you,
or discuss with you
some of the best
practices that you
could follow when
building Shiny applications.
And some of the
challenges that you
may face when working with
interdisciplinary teams, when
you want to deploy Shiny
applications to the cloud.
I am Ivonne Carrillo Domínguez,
the engineer manager at Bixal.
At Bixal,
we have several teams and
I've had the opportunity
to work in two of them, the data
science analytics, and cloud
computing teams, and these
are teams of 10 collaborate
together when building
data products.
And the story that
I'm going to tell you
is about this team's very
first Shiny application.
I've broken down this
story in three parts,
prologue conception,
development time, and going
to the cloud. In
each of those parts
I'm going to tell you some of
the challenges that we faced
and how we overcome them.
And spoiler alert,
we should have
gone to the cloud
from the beginning.
Let's start with the
product conception.
The first question
that we ask is,
how we are going to
collaborate, given
that we came from
the data analysis
that we were doing individually.
Well, now we needed
to code together.
You may know the answer, so
I'm just going to say it.
We used Git.
Some of the team members
were learning about Git.
They have to push and pull code.
Well, luckily,
we had this blogging
in RStudio that
can ease the learning curve, because
it can be tricky sometimes.
And why use Git? Well,
you want to be able
to share your code,
integrate everyone's
contribution,
and keep different
versions of your code.
This is on your local
but also in the Git platform,
and you can use any Git
platform, like GitLab
or GitHub or Bitbucket.
In our case, we asked the
infrastructure team,
which was a better tool because
what we wanted to do is just
focus on the development
and not worry too much
about the hosting.
So we wanted some pipeline
and some automation
that we were where we
were able to push our code
and then it was going to
be deployed to the cloud.
So they chose GitLab because
of the continuous integration
and continuous
development features.
So in this way, they were able
to use the tool that they felt
more comfortable with while
we were using the tool
that we were comfortable with,
RStudio.
Then we started using golem.
Golem is a Shiny framework
to build production level,
robust Shiny applications.
At the beginning,
I wasn't very sold
on using this tool
because it will
add a lot of R packages
and the scaffolding code
that I was very sure
that we were needed.
But then I really like it.
It it says you.
A very basic web
application where
we can build on top of it.
And one of the things
that it adds, for example,
is these scripts that it
will get you from the step,
a step by step,
guide you step by step.
So you can start
building your Shiny app.
For example, it will help you
configure your application
name, your unit testing,
your favicon,
and then it will take
you to the next step.
So it is a very nice
tool and I highly
recommend using
golem or a framework
like this one, especially
if this is your first Shiny
application.
Dependency management.
This is a concept that if
you are not very used to it,
it can be hard to understand
it, but it is very useful.
So we were facing the issue
that maybe my code was working
on my local, but it wasn't
working on another team
member, their environment.
That's because they didn't have
the R package that was needed,
or maybe they have it
but it was an older version
that was wasn't supporting
the function that I had.
So for that you
want to use a tool
like a dependency
management tool,
and there are several options.
You might as well just
use an R script
that will call your
list of dependencies,
or there are more sophisticated
options, like packrat or renv.
whatever the option you choose,
try to do it see
from the beginning
so you won't have to do
some reverse engineering,
remember all the tools that you
have installed, and then add
to the dependency
management tool.
If you do it from the beginning,
you won't have that problem.
Also it is OK to
explore an innovate
all the R packages
that are out there,
but for your application just
add the tools that you really
need for your
application to run.
So when it is on the cloud,
you are going to use backups.
Just the dependencies
that you need.
So just keep it simple every
package that
you add issues, potential
blocks or issues
that are more mundane.
And so it's a good
idea to keep it simple.
At this point, we were ready
for the development time.
So everything is already set up.
So we were ready to
build our product.
So how we were going to
distribute the workload.
Well, golem helped you to
create these Shiny modules.
You can think of them as
mini Shiny applications
that you are going to
call from the main script.
In our case, we had
five dashboards.
So we created one Shiny
module per dashboard
and we distributed them
among the team members.
The way that you are
going to separate the work
is going to depend on your
use case, your application,
or your team members.
Integrating the back end.
So this is how we did it.
We collected the data and
created some R data frames.
Then we loaded them into
the SQLite database,
which is a file.
And then set up the
database connection.
We create all the queries that
we needed and then connect
them.
Connect those results
to our dashboard chart.
But that wasn't real data.
It was just like sample data.
So we needed to really
be collecting data
on a daily basis.
We needed to build
some data pipelines
and then load in that data
into an Amazon Redshift and
then do it all over again.
So what is the
recommendation here?
Well, connect to your
database from the beginning,
even if that database does not
contain all the production
code.
It can be simple data.
But it is very important that
you start building your product
thinking that it's going
to be in the cloud
and then it's going
to be in production.
Keep it secure.
So at the beginning, we were.
This is very bad.
I know, but we were hard
coding passwords, AWS keys
and other sensitive information.
So what happened?
Every time that we were
pushing database credentials,
we needed to go to that database
that was already compromised
and change the credentials.
But what if we had pushed some
sensitive information that we
cannot really change?
Well, you need to go to Git
and remove that from your code,
but Git one of the
main features is
that you are going to keep
several versions of your code.
So even let's say that we are
talking about the password,
even if the latest version
does not contain that password,
you can just go back
to the previous commit
and the password is
going to be there.
So you have to go all the
way back through the Git history
where that password is present
and remove all those commits
from the Git history.
And by doing that, you are going
to remove some production code.
So it's going to be a mess.
So how to solve that?
Well, use environment variables.
You can use these the dot
Renviron file that's
going to be kept in
your local that's
going to have these
key value pairs
and you are going to call the
keys in your code like so.
And not only is
going to be secure,
but it's going to be ready
for the cloud as well.
Because what if you have a
database per environment?
Those credentials are
going to be different.
It doesn't matter because
your code is already prepared.
So only using the keys.
The values are different
in every environment.
So the only thing that you need
to tell your infrastructure
engineers are what are the
variables, the environment
variables that you need
through your application run,
and they are going to set up
with something similar to that.
Now going to the cloud.
This is a moment of
truth, because what
you want at this point
is just push your code
and hope it runs.
You want to build,
release and run.
Well, this is rare that
happens the first time.
And for us, it didn't happen
like the first 10 times.
So how do we solve that?
What we did is that every
time, we were doing a commit,
we were validating that commit.
GitLab has
these nice pipelines
where you can add some
steps to validate the code
that it is being pushed.
So, for example, what you
can do is the first step,
install the dependencies,
package your application.
And I think this was the selling
point for me about golem
because I wasn't really
sure about using it.
And, and when I saw
that goelm needs
to package your application and
then run it, it was weird to me
because I was thinking like a
package like dplyr or
ggplot that those are
there for you to use it.
And I didn't want my
application to be out there.
But don't think you like that.
When you package your
application, what will happen
is that it will run
or you all your code.
So that means that if you
forgot to add a dependency,
it's going to fail.
If you forgot to remove
some line of code
that they didn't have to
be, it's going to fail.
But if it can be
packaged, then it
means that every line of
code is a working line.
So that's a very good step
for quality assurance.
And then run
your unit tests, you
can validate the presence of
a title, a legend or a button,
just to know that your
dashboard is up and running.
Also have a development
cloud environment.
This is an environment
that is meant to be broken.
So it's for you to break and.
If it is not broken,
then it means that you
can push it to production.
And this is especially important
when you already went live.
And you can also have
a middle environment,
like a staging or
validation where
it's going to be an exact
replica of your production
environment.
And you can run some end
to end testing there just
to be sure that all the
functionality is there.
So those are some of the best
practices that you can follow.
And of course, there are more.
I will say that one
of the biggest ones
was the communication
between the infrastructure
engineers and the data team.
So I really recommend
you to get familiar
with all these concepts,
and I promise you
that communication
will get easier.
Remember this group
of friends that
are in somebody else's kitchen?
It might feel weird
at the beginning,
but once they agree
on the terms that they
are going to be
collaborating, how
they are going to collaborate,
the work gets easier
and they can start working
in harmony and having fun
and most importantly,
have great results.
Thank you.